these satellite images show an
Ammunition Depot in the Russian occupied
parts of Ukraine's herxson region in May
and in mid-june 2023
this attack is one of a number of
Ukrainian strikes on Russian military
infrastructure and supply lines in
recent weeks
as Ukraine continues the push to take
back territory Kiev has been using
British long-range missiles in an
attempt to degrade Russia's ability to
defend the areas it occupies
here's a closer look at the strategy and
the role of Western weapons
in late June Ukrainian missile struck a
bridge linking the occupied Crimean
Peninsula to the russian-controlled
parts of the helsan region Russian and
occupation officials said
this bridge played a key role in
supplying Russia's Frontline troops in
the south of Ukraine via Crimea
British intelligence said the roots
temporary closure doubled the length of
time it took for Russian Logistics
convoys to reach the front lines
the russian-appointed head of the Herson
region dismissed the significance of the
attack
Russian State media reported that rocket
fragments indicated the bridge was hit
with Storm Shadow missiles from the UK
Ukraine's stepped up strikes against
infrastructure deep in Russian occupied
territory came after London provided it
with long-range missiles in May storm
the missiles are fired from aircraft and
have arranged exceeding 155 miles enough
to hit Russian Logistics hubs and bases
this is dramatically beyond the reach of
high Mars launches sent by the US to
Ukraine which were modified to keep the
range within about 50 miles
last year Kiev successfully used the
tactic of targeting Russian supply lines
with high mass to retake the city of
Herson
however herxson was uniquely vulnerable
because Russian troops there could only
be resupplied over Bridges
the Ukrainian and Russian ministries of
Defense didn't respond to a request for
comments on the significance of the
recent Ukrainian attacks and the role of
long-range missiles
Britain's defense secretary speaking of
the use of Storm Shadow missiles in
Ukraine urge keeps Western allies to
provide more long-range equipment I
think the key here is to recognize that
if the Russians move out of range we
must work together internationally to
make sure that the equipment is given to
make sure they are back in range
in late June American and European
officials said the U.S was considering
approving a long-range missile system
for Ukraine in the meantime these
attacks show Ukraine's focus on
destroying the support system for
Russian troops while trying to preserve
troops and Western tanks